masco visage charlotte sur la tête et
blues de protection on est loin de la
fashion week de paris
mais ces accessoires vestimentaires que
porte le président emmanuel macron sont
tous qu'il y a plus tendance en france
il en manque cruellement de ce matériel
de protection
il en manque pour le personnel de santé
d'abord qui en utilisent au bas mot 40
millions de ces masques par semaine
avant la crise nous produisions en
france 3,3 millions de masques par
semaine fin avril nous serons à plus de
10 millions
nous aurons plus que triplé en quelques
semaines
même à ce rythme accéléré la france va
demeurer dépendante des importations
pour répondre à ces besoins la france a
commandé un milliard de masques et
organise un pont aérien avec la chine
la première livraison de 8,5 millions de
masques est arrivé lundi
une seconde livraison de chine 12
millions de masques cette fois est
attendu mercredi selon l'elysée c'est
bien à court terme mais insuffisant pour
sortir la france de sa situation de
faiblesse de vulnérabilité devenue
intolérable selon le président le jour
d'après ne ressemblera pas au jour
d'avant nous devons rebâtir notre
souveraineté nationale et européenne
il nous faut retrouver la force morale
et la volonté pour produire davantage en
france et retrouver cette indépendance
il ya les masques mais aussi les
respirateurs larmes ultime pour
combattre les cas les plus graves de
lakovic 19
un consortium de quatre grands groupes
industriels doivent fabriquer dix mille
respirateur d'ici la famille
ce désir d'indépendance pleine et
entière a affirmé ne sera pas assez pour
protéger tous ses autres travailleurs de
première ligne ceux qui sont en dehors
des hôpitaux et qui échappent au
confinement policiers pompiers livreur
caissier aucun de ces travailleurs n'est
pour l'instant équipée de matériel de
protection personnelle
les syndicats en réclame et menacent
d'exercer un droit de retrait ça ne va
pas changer dans l'immédiat a admis le
président le moment viendra pour son
administration de rendre des comptes sur
sa gestion de crise a ajouté emmanuel
macron et ça se fera en toute
transparence at il promis
mais alors que la france s'attend à
atteindre le pic de l'épidémie
probablement au cours de la fin de
semaine qui vient
ce moment ce n'est ni aujourd'hui ni
demain
ici marie-eve bédard radio-canada paris